hello rejects rag Luba here Jason Horton
Jason Horton here met in Zurich we
became best friends having baby on the
way we got sent this video that a lot of
people were asking for first person I
saw that requested it though was
Francisco Benitez so in law Senor nine
actors were almost cast as the Joker by
the channel looper we're getting this a
little differently whether animated on
film or on TV
Gotham's resident murdering maniac the
Joker is always memorable for every
actor who's given his unnerving cackle
to the Joker
there are plenty of notable actors who
just narrowly missed the part here are
some actors who almost played the Joker
Jose Ferrer now he might not be familiar
with Jose Diaz acting resume but the
Academy Award winner was a big deal when
producers were casting the original 1966
Batman TV series according to producer
William Dozier's original production
notes Ferrer was reportedly up for the
role of the Joker but the actor had
scheduling issues
because I think says that Romero is just
magnificent Cesar Romero eventually
edged for at out even though Romero
refused to shave his trademark mustache
despite forever missing the pot his son
Miguel went on to voice a slew of famous
DC Comics characters including Martian
Manhunter
Frank's do not Chuck real fast for Frank
they talked about how they were doing
that announcement of Cesar Romero and
they were heavy they almost had Jose
yeah that's interesting they're looking
for like Spanish actors yeah passion you
know I mean and like you know a little
bit like you know I feel like we would
never do that today no like we wouldn't
see Diego Luna played the Joker no would
then you don't work Michael is the Joker
yeah or Jennifer Lopez oh okay we might
be onto something I think we aren't
important here's a sales pitch Caesar I
didn't know Cesar Romero had a mustache
yeah that's why I always remember that
thing cuz he wouldn't you I remember
watching these and you could just see
his mustache I mean they just painted
over it I feel like it'd be cool to see
a joker with a mustache today mmm like a
Tom Selleck kind of Joker
yeah well thick moustache hello like a
very thick moustache no makeup just a
mustache it's a regular American guy
yeah the mustache
yeah all right Roger Mickey can dream we
could no no no dreaming if I know
anything one Hollywood comes to this
channel for the best oh yeah
I know what I'm talking you're doing
their job know where the fans well I
know DC fans and I know DC fans want a
joker with a mustache grant I just heard
about it but I know it's what's in high
demand
yeah Collider you better report on this
and here we go millions I have to stop
them Frank Sinatra madam West scampi
Batman attracted some huge Hollywood
stars is important villains including
Eartha Kitt burgess Meredith and Frank
Gorshin according to Burt Ward's memoir
Boy Wonder my life in tights Frank
Sinatra wanted in on the joke action but
arrived after Cesar Romero had already
signed on obses ting the hopeful Sinatra
while a crooning Joker certainly would
have made the clowns elaborate crew
tease even weirder Sinatra posthumously
scored his Joker connection in Rock
Steady's Batman Arkham Knight game where
his rendition of I've got you under my
skin plays a vital role in a Joker
related scene
ah Cory I didn't I never understood that
like why they chose that specific song
but I thought it worked so well in the
game Frank Sinatra though I don't feel
like would have been a good choice it's
just like I think he's overrated in
general whoa really
like you just don't like Frank Sinatra I
just don't really I don't not like him
and I don't like them I grew up on Frank
Sinatra can one of the few like old
school I guess singers I grew up on Hey
look at the moon something about the
moon right is that pretty much Frank
Sinatra no strangers in the night was my
favorite mmm strangers in the note like
what is this thing be like like talking
about man no Batman Batman hey that's
you listen uh you're gonna get out of
here okay all right bye
I got the penguin with me I got the
Riddler with me yeah I got the whole
pack with me yeah Tim Curry he's a
creepy [ __ ] no stranger to
playing monsters and creepy clowns Jim
Carrey missed out on the role of the
joka in two separate productions Korea
was among many familiar looks like he
could serve dozens short list for the
iconic 1989 Batman but the eternally
creepy Jack Nicholson ultimately won the
role Carrie then went on to record
multiple episodes of Batman the Animated
Series as the Joker before being
replaced by hard power reportedly
Curry's Joker was a bit too terrifying
for the QT demographic and it also
strained Curry's voice he did however
lend his laugh - a robot clown later in
the series
close enough think you have been great
to her Robin
yeah I think Tim Curry would have been
an amazing he's a really rocky horror
picture show he just looks so creepy
yeah he like looks for you yeah you
could put on the makeup which helps but
you need it already has the look yeah
like you just put the makeup on it's
just like yes extent you're gonna hit me
yeah I already feel molested but I'd
like a look at a photo of them you know
I think that's what people want to feel
and they watch the jeopardy yeah
feel molested least I do I usually feel
molested when I watch any movie if they
do you know how like this new Batman
they have like an older Batman yeah if
they do an older Joker like they get rid
of Jared Leto or something I think Tim
Curry to be a wonderful choice yeah it's
still acting still alive I think he's I
mean I think you have something like
health issues he was in the first
Charlie's Angels movie hmm yes I used to
lactic okay it's one Robin what is
Batman tragedies is the fact that Robin
Williams never had a chance to play the
Joker as a true comic nerd Williams
revealed in a 2010 interview with Empire
Magazine that he was thrilled when he
was offered the villainous role in
Burton's Batman often Nicholson first
declined a pod until Nicholson changed
his mind the two seem to remain cordial
however and Williams had a second chance
at the franchise as the Riddler in
Batman Forever but again the role was
yanked out from under him in favor of
Jim Carrey according to a 2006 IGN
interview Williams also tried to get
into Christopher Nolan's trilogy but was
pasta above that he pledged all actor
had ever wanted it so badly
John wick I could kind of see why they
might have went against first off it
just sounds like Tim Burton was offering
that role left and right yeah Robin what
I could see what he was so passionate
it's a plan but I just I don't know it
kind of felt like a little too obvious
of a choice yeah yeah cause like we
already see Robin Williams as like funny
crazy guy but then again it was Robin
Williams so even though that might be my
initial thought I feel like if he had
actually done it he probably would have
killed it absolutely yeah how'd you feel
about Riddler Jim Carrey's I barely
remember it very debatable yeah
seems it seems like a good idea me the
way how jim carrey did Riddler was just
Jim Carrey to another and I felt like
Robin Williams probably wouldn't the
same thing as Robin Williams doing
Riddler yeah you know but it sucks that
like Robin Williams didn't get a chance
to even do a voice of the Joker Joker's
the one animated cartoon character like
in TV shows and Batman felt like an
actual like straight-to-dvd adaptations
and stuff that seems to be something
very recognizing is like doing the voice
of the Joker at least and I don't know I
feel like Robin Williams wouldn't would
have done a great job yeah agreed agreed
John let's go also on the short list to
play Tim Burton's Joker John Lithgow
reportedly declared I don't but stating
that the character didn't seem
appropriate Bruce particular set of
skills
many years later yeah yeah play an
incredible viciously memorable serial
killer on Dexter proving that the depths
of each depiction of evil would have
been excellent against Michael Keaton's
Batman instead lift go wasted his time
in 1989 on a made-for-tv movie will
endure okay John let go huh
I think it's only you know cause of
Dexter you know he's a good he's really
good after well he was also the bad guy
cliffhanger yeah he's very low-key
though a little bit you think I don't
know I'm asking third Rock from the Sun
he's a he comes from stage he has a very
expression it but adds like a crazy
person do you think he'd be like a
little more like he wasn't okay we're
saying like a little bit more reserved
more that's her no we're supposed to
Joker's very strapping in and out there
perhaps yeah perhaps all right I think
John Lithgow is one of those actors who
is a little underrated even though he's
like really respected I feel icky
he could be bigger in terms of his
popularity because I think he's he's one
of those actors you can surprise he yeah
like he watched third Rock from the Sun
and then you watch them on Dexter and
it's like this guy could do [ __ ]
anything you know character actor she's
a great character actor he's a wonderful
one
Willem Dafoe there's any actor who
creeps me out more than anyone else it's
Willem Dafoe when you kind of look like
the Joker before you even sit in the
makeup chair your
an easy casting decision Willem Dafoe
was another actor who was briefly
considered for the 1989 film role simply
because he looked the part naturally he
later landed the role of the Green
Goblin in 2002 spider-man another
cackling supervillain who is pretty much
marvelous answer to the Joker nal Sam
Rockwell can't afford a Sam Rockwell
Willem Dafoe uh yeah I think Willem
Dafoe would have been a good what I like
with what they've been doing with the
casting choices of the Joker as of late
cuz Jack Nicholson is like one of those
shows doing yeah I could see Jack
Nicholson be injured when you hear like
Heath Ledger being a joke that's like a
surprise yeah yeah yeah or even like
Jared Leto that's kind of like despite
what you might have thought it I still
like the idea that one with a guy who
you might not expect to be the Joker
because it's very obvious you don't I
mean yeah like there's not a little I
feel like you need to needs to be more
work to be done when it's like you know
you're really like trying to fill this
role we already kind of look and act
like it I think maybe yeah
they're just kind of takes away a little
effect yeah that's weird it takes away a
little effect even though like yeah you
look creepy and everything yeah it's
like a hot girl playing a hot girl yeah
okay and willing to foe though man hot
girls you actually like there's so many
sex scenes and so many movies are human
there's that one movie there Greg
Kinnear it was all about sex
mmm I don't get how that guy does so
many sex scenes who is sleeping with
Willem Dafoe who is it
well played Jason well played Sam like
Sam Rockwell okay before clip yeah
peek through Sam Rockwell's acting
history and you'll see that he can do
just about anything he's rarely failed a
role even as the nameless Punk really in
two hours by Chris Ninja Turtles of the
doc not but producers ultimately went
with Heath Ledger instead leaving this
caliber of performance behind
a dream
yes Sam Rockwell's is like more he's
underrated I think he's very underrated
he's another actor who should definitely
be more I think one day he'll probably
get a role where he's just like I
thought he was ready party him see you
know he was an Ironman too so maybe
he'll get another chance of comic book
world like that's an actor where I'm
like Sam Rock will be great he hasn't
done anything like the Joker but I could
totally see him a little role like the
Joker like more along like I think he
would be a great addition from like the
Heath Ledger to JLo
Sam Rockwell same thing what we were
talking about not an obvious choice we
get an actor E and C still pulling it
off Adrien Brody we're just thinking
about another Dark Knight contender
Adrien Brody has publicly expressed an
interest in playing the Joker according
to movie pilot calm room is arose
regarding Brody making a joke cameo in
Batman vs Superman dawn of Justice but
Jared Leto ultimately took over in the
role in DC's extended universe Brody
stated at Kant in 2014 that no one ever
approaches him for comic book roles but
there's truly no better role to fill
with completely offbeat casting Ryan
Gosling according to the rap okay forget
the Gosling uh
Adrien Brody I knew anyone the Oscar
yeah no yeah yeah yeah I was thinking
about the other day when I was going in
the bathroom how he like kissed Halle
Berry and all that anyone the Oscar then
you really haven't seen him around I
think you made some poor choices and I
think he's yeah a lot of like
commercials which is fine I guess just
has a very specific kind of look I don't
but um I wouldn't want to seem as a
Joker it's the nose hate to break it to
you Adrian take it from two
delicious-looking gentlemen over there
yeah little baby goes little baby Chopra
knows you know you need a baby Joker
knows yeah you do
I don't know I don't do babies on
Thursday agent Brody has a baby Joker no
no I think you mean a baby Joker yeah if
he got no surgery if I would oh yeah
let's start a GoFundMe there's no
surgery
ryan gosling house suicide squads
directed David Ayer was aiming for Ryan
Gosling to play the Clown Prince of
Crime
well actually in that photo he kind of
looks like he could be a god Jared Leto
instead Gosling's pretty boy Jagger
would have been a bizarre contrast to
the twisted Joker's of years past but
it's hard to get the ever-changing Joker
totally wrong it's the Joker's paradox
the more wrong you make him the better
he gets and that laughs is on point
diagram thanks for watching subscribe to
our YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which Joker you
wish you could have seen you know I
think the things when you hear Ryan
gossip is a joker are you gonna go into
the movie and be like you know what I'm
already not scared you know I mean
that's fair but then again remember with
Heath Ledger was cast Heath Ledger was
like beautiful sexy yeah oh you know I
feel like he I don't think he Fletcher
was like one of those people that but
also we're kinda like I love Heath
Ledger you know I mean yeah looks plus
like Ryan Gosling like guys love girls
loves to Nicko's even becomes a joker is
that gonna put up like a barrier I feel
like you would have probably honestly I
feel like out of all these people on
this list he probably would have had a
much more different kind of joke yeah I
think about how like Ryan Gosling he's
kind of he's really known for his
subtlety he's known for being like
really comfortable and way back and yeah
even though it's like I mean we just we
saw wall I am [ __ ] another video
mention it maybe then he can do anything
I think he can't cuz I was thinking
about like I remember him and drive Lars
and the real girl the nice guy's crazy
it's like he's ready just what you're
gonna do finds a kiss yeah basically
mostly subdued but he would really have
to alter his voice if you were if you
were to do the Joker hey Batman yeah
Batman you like it
Joker Joker's like music I know that
means I got sexy yeah I'm sure a lot of
people might initially object against
that but it's like when you put a guy
naked I see the one thing that would
excite me about that Ryan Gosling would
be this guy transform ya transform ya
like it transformed yeah exactly totally
different voice and mannerisms and
everything and as much as Ryan Gosling
is one of my favorite actors because of
his emotional depth and subtle changes
I've yet to see a role where I'm like he
completely morphed his body language and
bullion and everything you know so but
I'm sure it's Frank Oz he would've
figured out a way well who's you don't
want us to play The Joker who's honest
oh let's see who do I like that would be
John Goodman it'd be a big Joker maybe
what about Michael Fassbender I could I
could see that yeah cuz he looks like he
could be an intimidating bad dude good
acting but he's busy too also
good-looking well the makeup and [ __ ]
you know it's like yeah I remember to
joke over says me I mean keep getting
Joker's like the high-pitched voice the
nasal and stuff and one of my favourite
Joker's I have seen was they did a
cartoon adaptation of The Dark Knight
Returns and that Joker was deep voice
hmm slow spoken yeah very subtle and I
thought I was really kind of cool yeah I
was like this sounds like the Terminator
yeah like on the fringes yeah exactly
and I I don't know I want to see an
actor like that
Javier Bardem what do you know something
but like a Josh Brolin playing the joke
like someone who has like that deep
voice and musalla it would be cool to
see a very different take on the Joker
cuz right now that Batman flick and be
all like a high
our code well looper you're fantastic
channel make sure to subscribe to these
guys watch the video and pull in the
link in description box you to this
channel subscribe to the real rejects
that is not a Hitler thing and that you
can follow it yeah this Jew over here
this you important here zone sure you
can get come subscribe to my kind of is
I want to take you and I'll respect you
and I'll love you and I will never take
you for granted
wow that's like anything ever ate wanted
to hear I'm desperate those are like the
safe words I rather than a book ones
yeah pick up artists book by Donald
Trump I read